The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GARY GENSLER: So this is
the last use case day.
And then Tuesday we'll wrap up.
And I know that you all
are preparing for finals
and writing final projects.
So it thins out at the end.
So I thank you all
for showing up,
those of you that
are still here.
I also want to compliment.
I didn't get through all
of the papers seriously.
But I did my best to read
them quickly last night
and today, that were
submitted for today.
And just like the ones on trade
finance, they're really good.
And if there was anything
that was kind of the learning
objective of this--
don't get too happy, James.
AUDIENCE: I submitted
mine just now.
GARY GENSLER: What's that?
Yeah.
I read it.
It was like two hours
ago, you put it in.
AUDIENCE: I've got a
slightly improved version.
GARY GENSLER: Oh, I don't
think Canvas let's that.
That's going to be a
double spend wouldn't it?
Sure.
Send it in.
It's to show critical
reasoning skills.
What is this new technology?
Why does blockchain
technology make sense?
And just like in trade finance
and identity management,
there's data that
really matters.
And we'll talk about this a bit.
But the data really does matter,
our identity and so forth.
But I wanted to turn
back to trade finance,
just for a minute, because James
had challenged the whole group
about supply chain management.
And Lauren was a little quiet.
But she knows I'm
going to call on her.
So this isn't a cold call.
But Lauren, you want to give
your view on this a little bit?
Lauren who worked in
supply chain management
for four or five years.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So the big thing, I worked in
supply chain sustainability,
and there's been a huge push.
The De Beers thing
touched on this.
There's been a huge push over
the past five to 10 years
to just increase traceability
and transparency through supply
chains to make sure conflict
minerals going to make sure
that things aren't
using a lot of water
in water stressed
areas and things.
There's been a huge
push for transparency
through the supply
chain and trying
to figure out how
companies can basically
like audit and assess their
suppliers, can take it
layers back.
And so one big thing now
is it's all done through--
most companies do it
through assessments.
So annually, companies
assess their suppliers
and hope that they submit
all this accurate information
and hope that their suppliers
are doing the same things
throughout the supply chain.
But there is very little
transparency into it.
It's very hard to verify.
And there's really asymmetrical
information on all sides.
So block chain
would be, I think,
for sustainability purposes.
Because right now you're just
like hoping that companies
are allocating the
proper time and resources
to go through and track their
raw materials and suppliers
and things.
But there's no real
verifiable or transparent way
for it to be done.
And so right now,
a lot of customers
are hoping that their
suppliers, they're taking them
at face value when
they say things
like, we don't use
child labor, we
don't source from
these certain regions.
But there's really
no way to verify it.
So I think a big opportunity
for blockchain and supply chain
is helping increase that
traceability so that you
know you're not coming from
places where child labor is OK.
Ideally, you're coming from
places with good safety
standards and things like that.
GARY GENSLER: Have
we gotten at least--
are you still on the rock
bottom minimalist side
of supply chain blockchain
management, blockchain
technology?
AUDIENCE: Marginally better.
GARY GENSLER: Marginally better.
But that's what's
wonderful about this class.
And even the eight
or 10 papers that I
read about identity management,
identity and access management
systems and blockchain
technology, ranged.
I don't think I read
any that were at a zero.
There were no
absolute minimalists.
But there were
some of your papers
that veered towards that.
And Alin, who's going to
talk to us probably sometime
during the day, I'd
say your paper veered
towards the most maximalist
side I'd seen yet in 23 classes.
AUDIENCE: With respect
to a certain definition
of digital identity,
which is probably
different than what
most people think about.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So we're going to
hear from Alin maybe
in 20 minutes or something.
But mind you, that's the
surprise of the class.
He's moved to the
maximalist side, at least
on one application for
blockchain technology, which
is also, I think, the
right place to be.
This is a technology that
might have use cases that work
and others that are just hype.
There might even be some
digital native tokens
that will survive.
And most, in my thought, won't.
But there might
be some that make
sense, probably more
blockchain technology
applications than tokens.
But we'll start going
through identity.
Again, we'll talk a
little bit about identity
before we get into it, identity
and access management systems.
But what is identity?
Then, the sort of
management of them,
particularly in a digital age.
Some state projects
in India and Estonia.
And then some
blockchain technology
projects, private
sector in essence.
And then, of course, some
of you might be graduating.
And we'll talk about MITs.
It is MIT, had to do that.
And the study questions were,
what are the trade offs.
What does it mean to be
self-sovereign identity?
And how might blockchain
technology address that?
And we'll see a show of
hands later how many of you
plan to get your MIT
diploma on blockchain.
I hope, by the way, that all of
you plan to get an MIT diploma.
But there are some of
you that are from Harvard
here and from other schools.
So maybe you'll
come back to MIT.
And then there was a
handful of readings
which, at least
from the write ups,
seem like they
reasonably did its job.
So what is identity?
This is an open question.
Tom.
What's identity?
AUDIENCE: I was going
to defer to someone
who wrote the paper today.
GARY GENSLER: You were
going to defer to somebody.
I see.
Who wants to say
what identity is?
James, you wrote
a paper for today.
AUDIENCE: You have
a birth certificate,
identifies you as an individual.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So is a birth
certificate identity?
AUDIENCE: No.
GARY GENSLER: Who's saying no?
AUDIENCE: I don't think that
the birth certificate is
an identity because
you can also be
identified, for
example, biometrically
or with your fingerprint.
So it is not only for
birth certificate.
AUDIENCE: But it is an identity.
Like if you go to the DMV and
you're going to get a license,
you need a birth
certificate to show.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
But is the birth
certificate identity?
AUDIENCE: It is not
what identifies--
AUDIENCE: It is like an
identifier for [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: Identifier.
It's a certificate.
Right?
Hugo?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, I feel like this is
super philosophical question.
GARY GENSLER: Well, maybe.
Do you feeling
uncomfortable with that?
AUDIENCE: No.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Like identity is
basically like who you are.
And all of the things that
prove your identity currently
are government issued documents
or like school issue documents
that prove that somebody else
has already done a background
check to make sure that you
are who you say you are.
GARY GENSLER: Brotish.
AUDIENCE: I think identity
is kind of contextual.
So sometimes it can
be a date of birth.
Sometimes it can be
your nationality.
Sometimes it can be your face.
It depends on the
context what identity is.
GARY GENSLER: Eric.
AUDIENCE: It should
be identity is--
going back to the
philosophical domain.
Identity is what defines
you as a unique individual
and differentiates
you from anybody else.
Right?
And use additional
instruments to serve
the purpose of identifying
you as an individual
to certain contexts, as Brotish
mentioned, that the identity is
inherent to a person, not
an additional artifact,
in my understanding.
GARY GENSLER: So how many
people agree with Eric?
It's something unique
that identifies.
AUDIENCE: I agree.
GARY GENSLER: You agree.
AUDIENCE: I think it has to
be something that you can
verify in order to be identity.
Otherwise it's just
a piece of paper.
GARY GENSLER:
Wait, you think you
have to be able to verify it.
But Eric was saying
that it's unique.
It's something
about our humanity.
It's about who we are.
AUDIENCE: I think,
as Hugo said, I
think it's very philosophical.
I think it's who I am.
So like my identity is like what
my name, what date of birth,
and my iris, and my
finger, this is who I am.
And I think what
you're talking about
is more like how can the
society verify that you are
the one who you claim to be.
So I think there's
different kind of layers
that we're talking sense.
GARY GENSLER: Alexis.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
like not unique in a sense
that it's like characteristics
that someone has.
But like maybe someone else will
have the same characteristics.
But it's more, Jahib just
said, like basically someone
can verify that what
you say is true.
Like if you have
these characteristics,
that's part of your identity.
But it's not like unique in
the sense that it's just--
GARY GENSLER: So, Alexis,
are you saying your identity
is not unique?
Or are you saying certain
attributes [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: It's unique for me.
But it's just like aggregation
of characteristics.
GARY GENSLER: Aggregation
We are going to
get philosophical.
This is good.
AUDIENCE: If you want
to get philosophical,
you can say that
the identity is what
the society imposes upon you,
or what the society makes up
of you.
Because, for instance,
a name itself
is not [INAUDIBLE] itself.
It's something that the society
or common culture construct.
GARY GENSLER: So you're saying
it's not just who you are,
but how society accepts you.
In a commercial sense,
in an economic sense,
identity is used
for so many things.
I do believe-- and maybe
it is philosophical.
I do believe that we
are each unique souls.
And so that's a
belief system, maybe.
But in an economic sense,
we have various attributes.
So those attributes
might be shared.
I know, in fact, yeah.
Woo.
So what is identity?
There is a dude up
there that I share DNA
with, exact replicable
genetic material.
But I, for one, think
that I'm unique from him
and I have a different identity.
And you can be guessing, while
you pull this down from Canvas,
who's who.
It's not a test.
What's that, James?
AUDIENCE: You're
on the left side.
GARY GENSLER: I don't know
which side you're pointing to.
AUDIENCE: Technically, the
left side of the photograph.
AUDIENCE: You're on the--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: As we see it, on the
left side of the photograph.
GARY GENSLER: I see.
Yeah.
You're correct.
But see, we're unique.
Different identities.
Same DNA.
Who has an iPhone
with face recognition?
So on Thanksgiving, Rob
hands me his iPhone.
He says, what do you see?
He says, just look at it.
And I look at it and I say, I
see a bunch of text messages.
Why?
And he cursed.
And he said, I handed
you my locked phone.
So whatever you think about
biometrics and iPhones,
it didn't work.
Or it does work.
I don't know.
So I handed him back my
iPhone, which a little older.
And I said, could you open it
for me with your thumb print.
And he couldn't.
So just for now,
we have a number
of sets of identical twins in
my father's family and so forth.
So he tried it with two of our
identical twin cousins, two
women.
And they, too, can open
each other's phones.
AUDIENCE: With fingerprints?
GARY GENSLER: No, with
their face recognition.
Not with fingerprints but
with face recognition.
So it just is a little
side story about identity.
Eric.
AUDIENCE: Just a comment that
there's a function in Facebook
that shows you a
list of photographs
that you potentially can
be identified and tag you.
So I keep getting pictures
of my twin brother, too.
So, yeah.
Very poor face
recognition today.
GARY GENSLER: You're identical?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GARY GENSLER: OK.
When I hear
fraternal, then I have
another thing about Facebook.
AUDIENCE: But there is
actually a much simpler way
to define identity.
Philosophy aside, there is
this physical human being,
and there's billions
of them on the planet.
And one simple way to
think about it is you
want to hash each person.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
We're back.
We're back to the
hash functions.
This is good.
AUDIENCE: But that's
actually what you want to do.
You want to hash each
person and get a number.
And the property of that
is that if you come to me
and I hash you, I
get some number.
And if you come again,
I get the same number.
So I know I'm dealing
with the same person.
GARY GENSLER: Even
if I put weight?
AUDIENCE: Even if
you put on weight.
I can hash because I can
use your iris, let's say.
Then your twin
brother presumably
won't have the same iris.
I'm actually not sure, but
I don't think you will.
So now a hash you, I
get the same number,
I know who I'm
dealing with, and this
solves a lot of the problems
in the business world.
Like KYC, getting a credit card
at a bank, stuff like that.
And it also solves the problem,
are you a new customer.
Well, is your hash one of
the new hashes that I--
is your hash a hash that
I've seen in the past?
So that's a very simple
way to think of identity.
And you put philosophy
aside and you
assume that there is some
physicality of human beings
that you can distinguish
between using
a hash function of some sort.
So the question is
like, how do you
implement this hash function.
GARY GENSLER: So
you're not really
putting philosophy to the side.
You're saying, that may
be all well and good,
but you can also take a
physical object, a human,
apply a hash function,
a cryptographic means,
and get a unique identifier
for that individual.
AUDIENCE: I have a
counter question to that.
So let's say you
hash everything.
I can have a counter feed
of like five things that can
essentially be the same thing.
And you'll just have five
different hashes for it.
Right?
It will still have to come from
a non-blockchain source for you
to be able to--
AUDIENCE: Well, it's not things.
It's human beings.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But for you to be able
to hash one person,
you can still reproduce
five other fake people
and have five different
fake identities
with a different hash.
AUDIENCE: So that's
the difficulty, right?
You can't actually-- if I
hash myself and I get a hash,
you will have a
lot of difficulty
producing another human being.
It's like finding the
collision in the hash function.
You have a lot of difficulty
producing a human being that
has the same hash as mine.
Because the hash function
is collision resistant.
And it's hard to come
up to clone me 100%.
For example, my retina,
even if I give you
all the data behind my
retina and you have it,
it's very hard to produce
a retina in your own eye
that you can scan and pretend
to be me, for example.
That's one way to think
of hashing somebody.
You just scan the retina.
And even though you
know the full retina,
it's of no use to you because
you have to put it in your eye
and go there and get scanned.
And it's like, OK, fine.
Well, our medical
technology is not there yet.
GARY GENSLER: [INAUDIBLE] And
then we're going to move on.
AUDIENCE: I'm just going to
say, if you want to take it--
it's not even your
physical representation.
Right?
Because you can change what
you are physically nowadays.
And so it's like what
you know, what you are,
and what you have, the
three things that you can
put into this hash function.
AUDIENCE: Well, it should be--
it should be.
You're right.
It's not the whole of you.
You have to do it
very carefully.
So the question is, how
do you [INAUDIBLE] person.
Because if you go by weight,
let's say the hash function
is your weight.
Well, that's bad.
Because you get collisions.
So you have to do it
very carefully, for sure.
GARY GENSLER: So, Eric, did
you have something to add?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
But actually,
the main point of your
elaboration is the biometrics
behind the whole--
because it's not the hashing
that's making this possible.
It's the biometrics.
Because you have to
actually hash something.
When you come from the
abstract construct of saying,
hash somebody, you're
actually saying,
you're hashing some
biometric attribute
that has to be unique
to get the hash.
AUDIENCE: I'm sure hashing
a person is an abstraction
for, let's say,
take a biometric,
it's actually
collision resistant.
AUDIENCE: The point, the
really important point,
it comes to biometrics.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
That's right.
And then the question is,
well, biometrics get stolen.
How do you deal with that?
Then you have to be
very careful with it.
There's nowadays,
you can actually,
if you aren't careful,
it can get stolen.
GARY GENSLER: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So to Eric's point, I think
that's still an identifier.
It's not really your identity.
Because like you
guys are saying,
you can replicate somebody's
retina, let's say,
1,000 years or 10 years
down line, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Perhaps.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: Or they replicate
somebody's fingertip.
But that doesn't mean
that you're replicating
their entire identity.
So I like the idea of
hash somebody's identity,
hashing a person.
But I don't think it's
just hashing their eye
or just hashing their--
AUDIENCE: That's right.
But I think you're
getting philosophical.
I'm looking through
the perspective
of a bank, a verifier.
What does a bank
actually need to do?
It just needs to map
everybody to some number.
And when you come back,
it needs to figure out
which number you are or
if you're a new number.
That's all you need.
And then, problem solved.
And then by the way,
personal data attributes,
you just link those
to those numbers.
It's not a difficult problem.
It's an orthogonal problem.
You solve that [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: So
let's agree that--
what Alin is saying
is he's not talking
about our soul or
our unique identity.
He's talking about something
that a verifier or a bank
might be able to do.
And then you could say here's
7 billion people on the planet
now.
And there'll be 10 or
12 billion one day.
But you could take
each one of them
and somehow have a unique
identifier, a hash function,
that has each of those.
Don't do it off of DNA though.
Because Eric and I,
you know, and hundreds
of millions of others would--
so DNA is not a unique
identifier for true identity.
So the concepts of
identity for things
that I think about
sometimes, some of the papers
were about three.
But there's attributes, a claim,
a credential, an attestation.
What would be an attribute?
Just any old attribute of a--
anybody?
AUDIENCE: Your retina.
GARY GENSLER: Your retina.
Or it could be your age,
address, citizenship, name.
A claim is, my name is Gary.
Or a claim might
be, I am so old.
Or I am a US citizen.
Or a claim might even be, I
have $5,000 in my bank account.
There are other forms of claims.
Or I do have a bank
account at Bank of America.
I don't think I have
$5,000 in it right now.
No.
A credential is what
we started with.
I think James mentioned it, a
driver's license, an ID card,
a utility bill sometimes.
I mean there's hundreds
of forms of credentials.
We think of the
governmental credentials.
The history of credentials
is interesting.
The first tens of thousands
of years of human kind
didn't have any.
And we started to have them.
Passports really aren't even
that old of an invention.
In the 16th century, the King of
England had some pass boarding.
But it was so that
his citizens could be
recognized in other countries.
It was so that their
rights would be respected
and somebody would
not be messed with.
I'm under that sovereign,
don't mess with me.
But in terms of a true
permitting system,
it was largely implemented
about 100 years ago.
Anywhere between 100
and 150 years ago.
It's not that old a system.
But it was all paperwork.
And I don't know if
any of you have ever
asked to see a grandparent's
or great grandparent's
or an ancestor's passport
or those documents,
if you have them.
But they're intensely paper.
In fact, if they're from
the late 19th century,
there's no photographs.
They started to have photographs
in the early 20th century.
And so it's a big change.
And the last 30 or 40 years
of digitisation of this
has actually made it a
little harder, in some ways.
I mean there's efficiencies.
But it makes it harder.
And then attestation is that
third party verifying it.
And that's what Alin
was talking about.
If somebody can verify your
identity, they're basically--
I make a claim.
My name's Gary.
I might give a credential,
my passport to show it.
The picture looks like me.
A human looks at it.
Lines it up.
Says all right.
You can enter the
country of Germany
or wherever I'm traveling.
They don't actually
know that I'm really--
but they do some verification.
So those are the
big kind of pieces.
Identity and access management
systems, the functions--
and these are just
taken from a bunch
of readings-- authentication
and then authorization.
Authenticating that I
have the bank account.
Authorization, I can use it.
Or authentication
I'm a US citizen.
Authorization, I can come
into the country of Germany.
So based upon some attribute,
somebody authorizes me.
Or something that
maybe some of you
have dealt with at some
stage of your life,
that first time you
went in and handed
a driver's license in so you
could take a drink at a bar.
Let me make it tangible.
That's like authenticating,
do you look like that person.
And then who are the
parties in this system?
Users, service providers,
identity providers.
Anybody want to tell me
about this ecosystem at all?
Alfa, you didn't write.
You wrote last time.
Tom.
AUDIENCE: Again, I didn't write.
But the idea of identity
provider is interesting.
It fits in our
conversation, right?
If we're talking about your
identity being who you are,
it's really identity
verification provider.
They're providing the documents.
GARY GENSLER: I
think that's right.
I mean, in a sense.
Though identity, in a
more philosophic way,
is who you are.
But yes, the
identity provider can
be somebody like the
state of New York
or the Commonwealth
of Massachusetts,
birth certificates, death
certificates, marriage
certificates.
Attribute authorities, like
certificate authorities,
are kind of a more
recent invention.
I don't know that they
existed 100 or 200 years ago.
But an attribute authority
says, these attributes,
we'll validate them.
They're central authorities
that say, yes, this is correct.
And certificate authorities are
particularly an invention of,
what, 40 years maybe.
The internet, 30 years.
AUDIENCE: I think the thesis
was an MIT thesis in 1976.
GARY GENSLER: 1976
thesis at MIT.
AUDIENCE: If I
remember correctly.
GARY GENSLER: Did
anybody want to say
what a certificate authority is?
Because they're in the
middle of all of that.
By the way, every time that
you go to the internet today,
a certificate
authority is involved
in that transaction, probably
100 billion times a day
around the globe.
Yeah, that's probably
the order of magnitude.
Probably 100
billion times a day,
a certificate authority is used.
Alin, you want to--
AUDIENCE: Sure, yeah.
GARY GENSLER:
Certificate authorities
are how we access the
internet all day long.
AUDIENCE: You want
an explanation
for what they are on the web?
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So on the web, you have
a bunch of websites.
Let's say you have
facebook.com and you
want to visit it and
give it your password.
So if you have evil
people like me,
I might set up a fake
server and pretend
to be facebook.com, mess
with the DNS records,
get you to visit my server.
When you type www.facebook.com,
you visit my server.
But you can't tell.
GARY GENSLER: DNS is
Domain Name Server.
AUDIENCE: But
anyway, the idea is
that when you
actually do a look up
from facebook.com
from an IP address,
that's actually very insecure.
And attackers can mess
with that and redirect you
to their servers.
And they might completely
replicate the Facebook page
so you might think you're
interacting with Facebook.
But you're not.
You're interacting with
an attacker website.
And you type in your
password and your user name,
and then the attacker steals it.
And then he just redirects
you to the real Facebook
and you won't notice
the attack at all.
Does that make sense?
GARY GENSLER: And it all
happens in nanoseconds.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And it's called the man
in the middle attack.
So what you do is you use
public key cryptography
to solve that problem.
You say, OK, let's give
each website a key pair.
So facebook.com will have
a key pair, a secret key
and a public key.
So now, the question
is, well, there's
a public key for
facebook.com, but how
do you know you have the right
public key for facebook.com.
Because an attacker could
also give you their public key
their fake facebook.com.
So now, how do you
distinguish between those two?
That's where the certificate
authority comes in.
So the certificate authority
signs these public keys.
And you have the public key
of the certificate authority.
You have a signature from
the certificate authority
on the public key
of facebook.com.
You're now ready to
trust that you're
dealing with the
real facebook.com
and you can encrypt
your password
to facebook.com using
your public key.
There's a lot of
public keys around.
I know.
I'm not sure if
that made any sense.
GARY GENSLER: So
we earlier learned
about public key
and private keys
as part of blockchain
technology.
But know that when Satoshi
Nakamoto wrote that paper,
she was just using
asymmetric cryptography,
public-private key cryptography,
that had been invented really
in the 1970s.
And then it adopted,
as the internet
came along, and took off and
had a lot of use in the 1990s
to secure the internet by 1996.
And the way that the internet's
secured on TSL and SSL
and these various
ways it's secured
was public key-private key
cryptography, a full 12 years
before Nakamoto wrote the paper,
but used for a different case.
But Facebook has a public key.
And all those public
keys of all the websites
that you visit every day,
there is a central authority
called a certificate authority.
There's actually a 100 plus
certificate authorities.
But certificate
authorities that say,
this is the Facebook public key.
So that when you go to your
Facebook or you go to Google
or you go to shop on Amazon,
you know you're actually--
so that's a corporate or that's
another form of identity.
It's not one with
soul, I would suggest.
That's not a negative
thing about Facebook.
I just don't think websites--
but you all might have
a different philosophy.
I didn't think
websites have soul.
Brotish.
AUDIENCE: It's not clear
to me how, as a user,
I know that I'm going
to the right website.
I understand certification
happens [INAUDIBLE]
But how do I know that I
have the right website.
GARY GENSLER: I'll try
to do it in lay terms.
And then you'll hit it.
There's kind of a handoff that
when you send that signal,
you're trying to access--
is it Facebook?
You're accessing Facebook.
They send you some information,
including their public key that
you're--
in essence, a
certificate authority
is automatically checking.
But Alin will give you
the more technical.
AUDIENCE: Let's use
a simpler example.
Let's say you want to
go to New York Times
and you want to read a
headline that says something
about some important things,
like tomorrow there's
going to be a snow storm.
Obviously you want to
know if you're dealing
with the authentic website.
That seems to me the problem.
So how do you deal with that?
Well, remember the New York
Times will have a public key.
It will have a
corresponding secret key.
So you visit their website.
It turns out that when
you download the website
from the New York Times
with that announcement
about the snow storm,
that's actually signed
with their secret key to verify
the website that you get.
You verify it against
their public key.
And you know that only
they know the secret key.
So only they could have offered
that information and signed it.
So then you know you're
dealing with the right website.
It's literally the New
York Times sends you
a signature over every piece
of information they send you.
And you verify it
against their public key,
which in turn you verified it
from a certificate authority.
GARY GENSLER: If you remember
the little bit of broccoli
we did earlier this year,
that asymmetric cryptography
with a public key
and a private key
also has digital signatures.
So you have, now, two things.
Let's go back to Bitcoin.
In Bitcoin transactions,
you have a public key.
And then somebody
signs a transaction.
And the math behind it,
the cryptography behind it,
is a signature and
a public key that
come from the same private key.
There's a way to do a
function to check that they
came from the same private key.
And the heart and soul of
what was invented in the 1970s
was not just that there's a
public key and a private key,
but also that you can
digitally sign it.
And then when the
digital signature
is compared to the
public key, it's
unique if they came from
the same private key.
So going back to
the New York Times,
the New York Times you have
both their public key and then
each headline, each
piece of information
has a digital signature.
And of course, you do
have a centralization,
a lot of centralization,
on the internet related
to these certificate
authorities.
Eric.
AUDIENCE: Just a point
maybe to clarify,
this is performed
at a protocol level.
That is not the user witnessing
any of these interactions.
It's done at the top of the
TCP ICP stack, this TLS, which
is the security protocol that
works with HTTP, which is web.
And this is where you
find that this little lock
in the browser that's
guaranteeing that that's
the website you're visiting.
Because the whole
exchange of information
that includes the public
key from the website
and the verification
is done by the browser.
You don't do
anything interactive.
GARY GENSLER: We
don't do anything.
That little lock
has that meaning.
And you could actually see
what certificate authority.
I only pause on that to
pause not only to tie back
earlier conversations about
public and private key,
but the whole internet is
reliant on these certificate
authorities.
And blockchain
technology might be a way
to step around and
have a new paradigm.
Kelly.
AUDIENCE: So for a
contextual example,
say I'm trying to access my
brokerage account or whatever.
And say I forgot my password.
Or every month, they want
you to replace this or that
to protect your account.
How does a person interact with
these various parties going
through that process when it's
trying to verify that it's you
gaining access?
What are the points
of contact for those?
GARY GENSLER: There
is an initial layer,
which we were just
talking about,
that you're actually
dealing with you're--
I don't know.
I'm going to make it up.
DE Shaw.
Or no, that's a hedge fund.
With--
AUDIENCE: Bank of America.
GARY GENSLER: Bank of America.
Fine.
That you're really
dealing-- so that's
what we were talking about that.
They are Bank of America.
And you're really dealing
with Bank of America.
And you don't even
participate in that.
But then there's another
layer that if you've
forgotten your
password, they're going
to ask you a bunch of questions,
like the usual questions
about who was your
first pet and who
was your first significant
other and things like that.
But at some point in time,
they'll freeze you out.
AUDIENCE: That's
the service provider
that you registered with.
That's Bank of America.
GARY GENSLER: That's
Bank of America
has their anti-fraud provisions.
What we were just
talking about is really
at the internet browser.
And in essence,
Facebook is the one
that's trying to be identified.
100 billion times a day,
some human around the globe
is trying to be
protected, that they
know they're dealing
with the right identity
on the other side.
We were talking
about human identity.
There's also the
identity of the websites.
And that's what we were
just chatting about.
Let me move on.
And then if I've
left you confused,
because you were asking
about what happens
if you forgot your password--
AUDIENCE: Right.
Like how do they verify
you, not you verifying them.
GARY GENSLER: How
did they verify you?
I would contend it's still
kind of a little archaic.
I mean, it's a little bit
like if you forgot your--
a couple of times you use
a username and password,
and of course if you
have dual authentication,
they might send you a notice
to another text message
or something.
But if you've forgotten
your password,
then it's literally backdoor
sort of saying, well,
to remember your question.
I never remember the questions.
I mean who is your first
friend in elementary school?
What was the first
car you drove?
It's crude.
And then they usually freeze
you out for fraud protection
after two or three
times of trying that.
And almost always,
there's something
where they can send it
to you another place.
Identity management,
some of the pain points.
What are we trying to solve?
And why would blockchain
technology maybe help us out?
Privacy and security
is a big one.
There are a lot of
thefts, identity theft.
How many people are in the room
have had their credit card--
this year, in 2018,
we're 11 months in--
have had their credit
card have to be replaced
because the bank got in touch
and said it's compromised?
Only about 20% of us.
I would have thought it
was going to be more.
I feel like I get one of those
calls every 18 to 24 months.
Maybe I shop too much.
Or my daughters are
using my card too much.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] big
enough to be a target.
Student banks tend
to be negative.
GARY GENSLER: You
think that's it?
I just assume that some
merchant has been hacked again.
I mean, every time a
merchant loses 1 million,
or 100,000, or 50
million accounts,
then the banking system needs
to send out those notices.
I chair a commission, Financial
Consumer Protection Commission
of Maryland.
And the credit union
advocates in Maryland
came to our commission and
said, we need some help.
We banks and credit unions
have to protect a lot of data.
But every time a
merchant loses data,
it's us credit
unions and banks that
have to replace all
the credit cards.
And they feel there's
an asymmetry, commercial
asymmetry, that the
banking sector is bearing
the brunt of other merchant's,
non-financial sectors, data
breaches.
And should the state of
Maryland-- this is a live
issue actually in front
of our commission.
Should the state of
Maryland change its laws
to put higher cybersecurity
responsibilities
on non-financial sector actors?
And the financial
sector would say, yeah,
that kind of feels you'd be
leveling the playing field.
And the merchants
are saying, you
can't do that on every
grocery store and bar.
It seems like it's a
little out of sync.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was going to say
that credit card theft like this
is a perfect application public
key cryptography.
The [INAUDIBLE] don't give
out your credit card number
to these folks.
Your credit card
should have a key pair.
It should have a secret
key and a public key.
And you give your
public key to Amazon.
And then how do you pay Amazon?
Well, you sign with your secret
key that's on your credit card.
So nobody knows your secret key.
It's on your damn card.
Never lose that card.
And problem solved.
They can steal as many
public keys as they want.
Problem solved.
Same thing with the SSN.
Why would you share that--
GARY GENSLER: I
disclosed to you.
He became a maximalist, almost.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I'm
talking about public crypto
here, not without consensus.
Although, consensus can
be a very important part
of all of this.
GARY GENSLER: Almost.
Almost.
All right.
So let me just hit.
So in terms of the
big pain points--
privacy and security, a
bunch of identity theft,
forged credentials,
back to the passport
or the driver's
license or the credit
card, a forged credential,
whatever that is.
And of course, just how do we
update our personal identity
for any time we move?
And this term PII
is three letters
you'll learn in business.
Because at some point in time
you'll be running a business
and somebody will be coming
in, your chief of information
officer, and say,
we've had a breach.
And unfortunately we
broke some laws, too.
Because in the US and
in other countries GDPR,
you have to protect
certain data.
And it's usually called PPI.
It's usually the bucket of
data you need to protect.
But every time you update your
personal information, how do
you how do you keep it updated?
Ross, was there a question?
AUDIENCE: I just had a question
back on your Maryland example.
I make the
assumption, maybe it's
wrong, that if your
commission allows the banks--
or passes that regulation--
GARY GENSLER: We're
just an advisory.
But if we recommend to
the General Assembly.
AUDIENCE: That the banks
are not going to lower
their fee to the merchants.
So what's the dollar number
that they're trying to push?
In other words, I'm trying
to size the pain point.
What's the amount of
cost to those banks
that they're trying to
move to the merchants
and thus drop from the
bank's bottom line?
GARY GENSLER: I
don't have a figure.
It's a very good question.
What we know is that the overall
statistics on fraud and credit
card is, I think, high
teens basis points.
I can't remember, 15 or 18
basis points but less than 20.
And it's more than 10.
So Visa Network charges
270 basis points or so.
And the fraud part of it's
15 or 18 basis points.
AUDIENCE: And the issuing
bank gets how much of the 275?
GARY GENSLER: 200 or so.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So they want to [INAUDIBLE]
whatever that is.
GARY GENSLER: But I don't know--
and this is particularly
credit unions are coming to us
and saying there's an
externality, the merchants,
the gas stations.
All right.
So you're saying, I
know which way you
would vote on our commission.
So what's going on a little
bit about data breaches?
I just tried to sort
of list anything
over 100 million customers.
But then I had to put Facebook
in because it was 50 million.
But these are just like a dozen
or so really big data breaches.
There are so many data
breaches in 2018 alone
that you couldn't list
them on a page like this.
This is the last five years of
100 million people or more data
breaches.
So there's a problem
here in cyber secure.
And this is just the US.
Brotish, didn't
the Indian system--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
more than a billion.
GARY GENSLER: 1.1
billion people's IDs
were hacked in India.
It was announced in
January of this year.
And so, it's a lot going on.
And every once in a
while, politically
it captures the attention
of particularly Equifax did,
Facebook does.
Wells Fargo, I think the
breach was 3 million.
It's not even on this.
It wouldn't get to
the 50th page by size.
But Wells Fargo had
other issues that was
capturing the public attention.
Kelly.
AUDIENCE: Just taking
the Marriott one
as an example, that's been the
most recent one in the news,
I think.
It's so costly to
these corporations.
I think Marriott
even said that they
would pay the fee to replace
passports for those affected.
I mean, maybe it's a drop
in the bucket for them.
But in terms of the
value in pain points,
sort of like you were
talking about, it's a lot.
GARY GENSLER: It is a lot.
But one of the challenges that
blockchain technology solutions
is adoption.
How do you get Marriott to
contribute to a new system
if you come up with a really
clever, creative, new system?
Because there are so many
thousands of merchants
that are trying to deal with
their cybersecurity risk.
And Marriott, all of a
sudden, has all these costs.
But how you get them involved in
your new blockchain technology
solution, I think it's just
an adoption issue, which
somebody might solve.
Or as Ross says,
well, wait a minute.
If the banks were to
just [INAUDIBLE] right?
AUDIENCE: If they
want to cut the fee
and let everybody
else-- then that's fine.
But the merchants have
no bargaining power.
GARY GENSLER: That's true.
AUDIENCE: So they cut the fee.
GARY GENSLER: So a couple
of state identity projects.
Estonia has e-identity.
They started in 2002, well
before blockchain technology.
And it's run on a software
called X-Road software.
And while some folks
might think of Estonia
as a blockchain friendly
nation, does anybody
want to take a guess whether
this software has blockchain
technology?
What's the consensus?
No.
It's not.
That doesn't mean
it doesn't work.
But they've sort of
wrapped themselves
in this sort of spirit of
we're a blockchain nation.
And they also have e-health
records and many other records
that are going online.
And it may be, at some
level, inspired by that.
They have 1.3 million
people in Estonia.
I think a bigger state
actor in the challenge--
sorry, Brotish-- is Aadhaar.
So there's a national
identification system.
And it was promoted really for
inclusion, financial inclusion,
and a way to get government
assistance and welfare
to hundreds of millions of poor.
India at the time that
it was rolled out,
well over half of India did not
have a banking account at all.
12 digit ID and biometrics,
being fingerprint and iris
scan, I think they would deal
with the identical twin issue.
I think, from my little example
that my twin brother Rob's
finger didn't open my iPhone.
But there's been
a lot of problems.
And that's not a
blockchain project either.
But my read of it is Aadhaar--
and maybe Brotish
has some views--
has done some very
positive things in India.
But it's also come with
some very scary things.
Brotish.
AUDIENCE: It's a quick nugget
of information about Aadhaar.
It was the fastest
system in the world
to reach 1 billion users,
faster than Facebook
or any other online platform.
And [INAUDIBLE] optional, I mean
it was not a mandatory system
for people to get it.
It was optional system.
But it was the fastest
one to reach 1 billion.
GARY GENSLER: But it's optional.
But you can't get your
government assistance
any longer if you're
not in it, right?
AUDIENCE: It's not like that.
So actually, there has been
some government efforts
to make it that way.
But then the court actually
rejected those proposals.
So they said that you cannot
make it mandatory to make
people receive
benefits based on this.
So whoever has that,
they might have some ease
of obtaining those benefits.
But it's not like without it,
you cannot get [INAUDIBLE]..
GARY GENSLER: So Brotish
is saying it accurately.
But the court only ruled that
this year during 2018 I think.
And for a while, hundreds
of millions of people
thought that's the only way
I can get my assistance.
But the 12 digit ID
and the biometrics
has produced a system where,
along with a payment system
where you can do a QR
code right on your iPhone
and get goods and services,
and it's pretty efficient.
But it's one national system.
One national system and there's
been a lot of challenges.
Not just the hack, but also
some mistakes sometimes.
And based on those
mistakes, people
feel like they've
lost their identity.
I mean, they're still
this human that they are.
But they've lost it in
a governmental sense.
And thus they've stopped
getting their assistance.
And there's occasionally
reports of suicides,
and reports of deaths,
and things like that
where people are no
longer recognized
in the system because
of their Aadhaar ID.
So there's a lot
of public debate
in India about the net benefit
versus some of the costs.
Self-sovereign identity,
four things I think about.
People and entities
control their identities
more than we have now.
This is a concept.
We have direct access
without some intermediary.
Our identity is transportable.
But not our human identity, but
the attributes of our identity.
So I use the term
more loosely here.
And then, it's widely
usable or interoperable.
Self-sovereign
identity-- what's that?
AUDIENCE: I was just
thinking [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
I kind of remembered
that back and forth.
Self-sovereign identity does not
rely on blockchain technology.
It's a concept in a debate about
should we go back to something
that we, in a sense, had in
the 19th century and even
early 20th century that we
could walk into any store
and there might be other
forms of censorship.
There are certainly many
prejudices and racism
and all sorts of challenges.
But we could walk in
without a document.
We weren't walking in.
We might have some gold,
some money in our pocket.
They would take the gold
coin or the silver coin.
Self-sovereign identity is
also thinking about can we
have the individual hold
their credentials as we
held a physical
passport but hold it
in a wallet in some way.
Ross.
AUDIENCE: Just your example
of the 19th century ties
into the question
that I had, which
is doesn't this only work if you
also have a decentralized money
system.
Like go to your example.
Only reason that works
is because people
could go in and pay with a
completely anonymous form
of money.
Unless you have a
real broad, say,
Bitcoin distributive
system, your bank
will require you to waive this.
When you sign up
for a bank account,
you will have to waive this.
And it's gone.
They just will.
GARY GENSLER: So Ross is
raising, well, will this even
work unless you have a truly
decentralized money system.
I don't think it's reliant on
a decentralized money system.
I can see your point that it's
benefited by a decentralized.
AUDIENCE: Any commercial
transaction you have,
the counterparty--
Facebook will make you waive.
Because they want
the information.
And Google, that's right
you could cut yourself off
from all those things.
But they'll just make it as
part of the contract, part
of the access, that you waive.
GARY GENSLER: So
self-sovereign identity,
concept that all of us humans
could control our identity, not
just our birth and our
nationality, but maybe even
our digital footprint,
our spending patterns,
and so forth.
And Ross is raising, well,
maybe Facebook and Google
wouldn't transact with us
as a commercial reality.
You're saying their market
power, they might cut us out.
I think some might try.
And that will be--
this hasn't been really adopted,
self-sovereign identity.
AUDIENCE: Hell of
a question for you
Consumer Protection Commission.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
Maryland probably won't be able
to weigh into that too much.
The benefits of taking identity
access management systems
onto the blockchain technology,
and eight or 10 of you
wrote papers on this.
Does anybody want
to comment on--
this is like, my summary,
some of the benefits.
You can address verification
costs and fraud.
You could potentially lower
some of the cost and fraud.
I think you can
trace provenance.
You deal with
censorship and so forth.
And truly, I think you
can help on privacy.
But the challenge is--
the real challenge
is that if you're
storing personal identifiable
information on a blockchain,
blockchain technology
works by distributing
the data to all the nodes.
And so the initial write ups,
three and four and five years
ago, were, like, well, could
you put self-sovereign identity
in essence in a
blockchain and store it?
And everybody
started to say, no.
You really can't do that.
Because you're not going to put
all my personal stuff on 10,000
nodes.
AUDIENCE: So I mean, the
first benefit there, I think,
should be prevent
identity theft.
Because the main security
goal of any identity scheme,
including the one
I described, is
you want to prevent
identity theft,
to prevent impersonation--
GARY GENSLER: I'm sorry.
I'm going back.
I just chose not to
read through this page.
I'm agreeing with you.
I mean, these are the pain
points it would all address.
AUDIENCE: And in
general, I think,
when you think
about identity, you
have to look at it
through that lens.
Because what else is
identity for if it's not
for preventing people to
claim they're someone else?
That's what an
identity scheme does.
If your scheme doesn't address
that fundamental problem--
like by the way, all of
these startups don't.
Because SSN numbers
are still out there
and require [INAUDIBLE].
So as long as that's--
GARY GENSLER: Social
Security Numbers.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Say goodbye to prevent
identity theft.
What are you doing then?
GARY GENSLER: I think,
I'll go here and then Hugo.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And something that was not very
much addressed in the readings,
I thought, was also the fact
that if you used a blockchain
technology, so evidently not.
It's immutable.
So it's often seen
as a good thing.
But here in this case, normally,
like for example in Europe,
normally in the
internet, you can
request to delete
information you have
if Google has a link which
mentions you for instance.
But here, you wouldn't
be able to do it.
Because the
information is there.
If someone steals or even
if you want it deleted it,
somehow you can't
because it's immutable.
So how can we deal with this?
GARY GENSLER: So you're
raising a point that in Europe
under the new privacy
law, the GDPR,
you have a right to be forgotten
or right to be deleted.
And so how can blockchain
technology interact and work
within that framework?
If your actual information
is on the blockchain,
I think you're right.
I think it's very hard.
But I do think there are
solutions if it's just
a hash of your
information that's
being stored on the blockchain.
AUDIENCE: Yes, but
they were mentioning
in the reading as
well the fact that you
can store all the data,
basically, of the blockchain.
And then when you
transfer it, you just
say like as a certification, oh,
yeah, this is my information.
And it is true.
You can verify it is true.
But you cannot have like--
GARY GENSLER: The
actual information
on a distributed network.
Kelly.
AUDIENCE: I think that's a
really interesting point.
One of the sort of
use cases I think of
goes back to the
original attributes
you were talking about.
So for example, what
about citizenship?
If in your digital
identity it says
you're a United States
citizen and that changes,
can that be changed if it's
immutable, A. And then B, what
about those privacy issues?
For people that do
not have, maybe it's
not a fully verifiable
citizenship,
then we have a whole host
of problems there as well.
GARY GENSLER: So I think
you raise a good question.
But this is one of the
challenges of any identity
database.
But it's also a challenge of a
money database called Bitcoin.
You have ownership today.
And tomorrow you might
no longer have the coin.
Today, you might live
in Massachusetts.
But a year from now when
you get your fancy job
and wherever you
are, you might not
live in the Commonwealth
of Massachusetts.
So I don't think it's
just citizenship.
It's just the
updating the records
and the attributes, that
you no longer can vote here,
can no longer--
AUDIENCE: It just goes
back to the trade offs
that we were originally
talking about.
There's a lot of--
it certainly helps
a lot of things
like preventing identity theft.
But there's also a lot
of other [INAUDIBLE]..
GARY GENSLER:
They're challenges.
But I think that
challenges is surmountable.
AUDIENCE: But even
though it's immutable,
you can append new information.
So isn't that the whole
purpose of blockchain.
Your citizenship may change, but
then you append new information
saying that your citizenship
has been updated.
And that becomes the
source of truth now.
GARY GENSLER: I'm
agreeing with that.
I think that's correct.
I think that's a
solvable challenge.
Hugo had his hand up.
And then we're going
to go on just to--
AUDIENCE: So I'm going
to question the idea
that having a blockchain
means identity theft is
no longer an issue.
I think it makes
it a bigger issue.
What happens if you
lose your private key
or if somebody finds a
private key or somebody
cuts your eye out or whatever?
But really, if somebody steals
your identity, then it's gone.
You're not getting it back.
GARY GENSLER: Oh,
steals your private key.
Your identity
identity is stolen.
AUDIENCE: Steals
your private key.
If you don't protect
that with your life,
then your life is gone.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
I think Hugo's raising
the right question.
But that just means that's
not the right solution.
You can't pin it all on just
one private key that's lost.
AUDIENCE: Well, the answer is
also use multiple biometrics.
And yes, sure, if you lose your
hand, your eye, your retina
and you go to the
DMV, maybe they'll
make an exception for you.
Hopefully like 10 people
ever show up that way.
GARY GENSLER: Let me try this--
plow in for a second of
what are the projects.
And this is a short
representation.
I could have made three more
pages of representation.
I'm going to hit three or
four of these just for fun.
There's three or
four that are ICOs.
I'm going to choose
to skip all of those.
But there are, I want to mention
that Civic Secure Identity,
Existence IC,
Sovrin which gets--
S-O-V-R-I-N-- but Sovrin
that gets a lot of write ups
in other papers were all
ICOs, Initial Coin Offerings,
to use a token to incentivize
a system of, usually,
self-sovereign
identity at some point.
None are up and running yet.
And I have my doubts about
some initial coin offerings.
But there are three or four.
And there were probably
six or 10 others
that I didn't quickly find.
Bitnation's an
interesting project
that literally you
can voluntarily
get a citizenship in Bitnation.
It is a decentralized
borderless voluntary nation.
But the keyword is voluntary.
They don't have a UN membership.
They're not part of the
World Trade Organization.
They have no geography.
But the concept is, you can
get a Bitnation passport.
And you can get
some authentication
through that about some
attributes about your birth
and things like that.
There is a standard setting
group, Distributed Identity
Foundation that we're going
to talk about in a minute,
and I'm going to
show a slide, which
is just a whole bunch of efforts
coming together and saying,
well, maybe we can do some
standards around this.
And then there's Rebooting
Web-of-Trust that runs events.
I think their only
economic model
is to make money on the events.
But some of their research
and some of their papers
are very interesting, that
you can read about this.
And not listed on this, one area
that's spending a lot of time
on self-sovereign identity is
the World Wide Web Consortium,
W3C.
You can go and on GitHub you can
read all sorts of information
from W3C about
self-sovereign identity.
And they're promoting
ways to do digital ID,
and trying to form standards.
So I think W3C, which is not
really a blockchain project,
and this Distributed
Identity Foundation,
for any of you that are
actually interested in pursuing
some of this, you want
to stay abreast of it.
Because it's the standard
setting also that I think
will be relevant.
But questions or
thoughts for those
who have done research
on some of these?
Other than Alin who
we've heard from a bunch.
All right.
What's your question?
AUDIENCE: Well, my
first thought is
they don't solve identity
theft in the United States.
GARY GENSLER: They don't
solve identity theft
in the United States.
AUDIENCE: Why?
Because there's a certain
policy by the US government
that asks everyone
to accept SSNs.
And if James has
my SSN, then James
is me for all
intents and purposes.
So that is a policy issue.
So these companies are
basically a very inefficient way
to change the policy.
Hundreds of millions
of dollars being
invested in all of these guys.
And by the way, all of
them do public key crypto.
It's not like something
revolutionary here.
But at some point, some of them
will get some market share,
maybe convince a few banks.
And maybe those banks will
convince the government
to start doing--
GARY GENSLER: So you're saying
that an underlying challenge,
at least in this
country, is that we
have an antiquated public
policy related to a tax
ID called social
security number.
And initially, social security
numbers were not even a tax ID.
Initially, they were to
participate in a retirement
program called social security.
And you were not
legally required
to have a number in the 1930s or
'40s when it first came about.
I didn't get my social security
number until I was 14, I think.
Now you pretty much get them
at birth in this country.
You can't use it for much.
You're not working.
But you're saying it's a
public policy challenge,
at least here.
I would say in every
country, there's
some public policy
challenges that
are very real around how
attributes of identity
are measured, whether it's
off of taxes or birth records
and so forth.
Can I hold?
Because I want to just
hit two other things.
This Foundation, these are all
the people in this Foundation
doing all of this work.
It's just a list that
you can look at later.
And they've set up--
and I apologize-- they set
up sort of this whole idea
about decentralized
ID and server.
So they have a whole program.
It's not a small effort that
they are investing in this.
And I only put it up to say,
there is a lot of energy.
And Alin might be right, it's
all fraught with some risk
because it's on the backs
of government ID systems,
not just in the US.
Public key infrastructure
could change.
And a lot of these concepts
are on decentralized public key
infrastructure.
Basically, where are
these public keys?
Whether it's Facebook public
key or any public key,
where is it stored?
I suspect, Alin, that you'd
say this is at least going
in a little better direction.
This is a key part
of just saying,
instead of the public key
and having these certificate
authorities, to
have a secure way
to store the public
keys in a decentralized,
hashed, using hash functions
and blockchain technology.
And I think all
of them have this
in the middle of it somewhere.
AUDIENCE: It's a
consensus problem.
You want to agree.
Everybody needs to agree
with Facebook's public keys
otherwise we're in trouble.
Because you might use
my fake Facebook server.
So it's really just
a consensus problem.
It's not about hashes, security.
Forget about that.
Everybody has to agree what
Facebook public key is.
And that's where the
blockchain comes in.
GARY GENSLER: Sorry.
Shawn.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to answer Alin's question.
I don't think that's a
public policy problem.
If you want to change
the SSN system,
you have to change
the entire system
of how the banks operate,
how the insurance companies
operate.
And the cost, the
social cost, is
much greater than just changing
the [INAUDIBLE] key itself.
I think he's entirely coming
from the point of view
for the implementation of
[INAUDIBLE] consideration
of the hidden economic cost
of such implementation.
AUDIENCE: But there
is the Patriot Act,
which says banks have to send
your SSN to the government,
which basically means banks
need to continue using SSNs.
So in some sense, you're right.
But also, government
has to do something.
GARY GENSLER: So let's move on.
I don't think it's
just here in the US.
What's happened is the
attributes of our identity,
or our credentials of identity--
whether it's for tax systems,
for banking systems--
in the last 30-odd years, as
we've digitized, and also post
9/11 and terrorists,
we started to use
all of these things for
anti-money laundering,
know your customer.
So the financial
system, the tax system,
and our identity
systems have now all
been kind of linked up, and not
always with the best intent.
I mean, maybe they were
the good intentions.
But with not with
the best results.
And it's part of why I
thought, if we were going
to cover blockchain technology
in the financial sector,
identification systems were
really important as well.
Because it's so linked up
with banking and finance.
And that wouldn't
have been the case
before the digital revolution
and the internet and so forth.
I think this is the
last cover slide.
But this is self-sovereign
identity platforms.
Basically right now, if we
want to keep our identity,
if we want to keep our
identity and only give it up,
a platform could create
and enforce rules
governing the workflow.
This is a little thing
called bitsonblocks.net.
But pretty much
most of the startups
are using an
architecture around this.
This happens to be Bits
on Block's view of it.
But it's basically, I'm going to
keep my attributes of identity.
And I choose when
I can give it up
and when it's used,
authorities, and issuers.
So I think I have hopefully--
oh, yes.
MIT.
That's where I wanted to go.
So what did you all think?
You read the little
article about your own--
you going to get in it?
James, you going to get your
blockchain blockchain diploma?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
[INAUDIBLE] I have
some experience.
I started trying to
get hold of my diploma
back in 2012 for a degree
that I got in 2007.
My university was
declared independent
from the University of London.
There was a whole record messup.
I'm trying to get a
copy of my transcript.
GARY GENSLER: And
you can't get it?
AUDIENCE: I had to go through
many different people, say, oh,
can I get it?
And they'd say, oh, we have
to contact the old university
because we were part of them.
GARY GENSLER: I'm
going to shorten your--
so how many of you are going to
get a blockchain backed diploma
when you graduate MIT?
All right.
A quarter of you.
And those that aren't, who
didn't raise their hand?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: Oh, you will.
Wait a minute.
I didn't see any
hands go up over here.
So you're not?
I don't care really.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: Oh, you did?
I want somebody who
didn't raise their hand.
Why aren't you going to get it?
AUDIENCE: For me, it's just
pure lack of information
about the process.
How to get it,
what I have to do.
So I don't know yet
if I will or not.
GARY GENSLER: So
you're just saying
there is an information curve
you have to learn about it.
The people that raised their
hands and said you'd get it,
how many of you will
also get a paper diploma?
You want something for the wall
or for the significant other
or for the children
or the parents.
Right?
There's still
something about that.
I don't even know where my
college diploma is, by the way.
But you still want
that piece of paper.
Was there anybody
who was only going
to get a blockchain diploma?
And any of you that go to
a different university,
do you wish your university
had a blockchain diploma?
Nobody's going to speak up.
Maybe not.
All right.
So it's a novelty.
It's MIT.
We're innovative.
We have it.
I hope you all do
come next Tuesday.
It will be our
last time together.
I'm going to try to wrap
up with some ground truth
as to what I think the whole
topic and this subject is.
This was meant to be about
the business of blockchain
technology, getting through at
least enough of the details,
knowing those details,
and then saying, well, how
does that apply to the markets.
Hopefully, you feel
that you've gotten,
and Tuesday we'll summarize it
all, some critical reasoning
skills that you can sort through
the hype and the reality.
And those of you that
came in maximalist,
you're probably
more in the middle.
Some of you that were
minimalist maybe came--
well, maybe you're still,
but you came a little--
because I thought that was
the right place to teach.
And you've all given
me tremendous feedback.
And I've learned a
lot from you all.
But let's keep it going.
See you on Tuesday.